fait vraiment des l'applaudir ça va le
réveiller aymeric lompret
[Applaudissements]
c'est une fois ci on pourra mettre une
musique un peu plus sympa et cool à vous
avez pas ça non j'aime tant déçu un
petit sardou tu vois un truc qui
réveille évidemment face à palerme avait
eu sa part appelé les patrons à la pêche
ça va ou non
voilà je vais me faire larguer par un
copine je m'attendais vraiment une
réaction un peu positifs d'autres fleurs
un soi disant je les tromper que sa
soeur je vais pas que c'est sa soeur
jumelle c'est quand je me suis tapé la
mer j'ai vu la photo tu mets ça sur la
table de chevet gicquel boulet vous avez
fait que ça oui j'ai fait ce qu'on va
demander cette semaine jean luc à temps
ça fait mal aux fesses alors je sais pas
de quel côté faut le prendre mais
apprécie bien oui mais est-ce que vous
défier sur tout le lot de tout ce que je
veux c'est bon le truc moi j'ai regardé
à tes temps ça ça fait mal au cul non
j'ai regardé je tombais sur affaires
conclues sur france 2 à vous alors à
leicester je crois affaire conclue au
début je trouvais ça beau look à dire
les gens qui sont qui ont pas trop
d'argent tu sais qui viennent devant les
derniers objets de leur grand-mère toi
qui vient de mourir et tout ça assez
symptomatique d'une société en crise oui
et quand j'ai vu la tune qui se faisait
les gars non mais je suis allé voir ma
grand mère je vis ma vie ça dépote
mettre au rugby
là je suis content parce que je suis
content parce qu'en plus
sa règle a tué l'alzheimer donc c'est à
dire que je peux je peux me vendre son
lit et 10 rebonds
le lendemain j'arrive gibralta pas de
lit et puis on achète un et du coup moi
je le vends et lendemain jarrige t'as
pas de lit et du coup lendemain le vent
après l'achat et moi je dis jour au
lendemain j'arrive dire oui t'as pas de
lit je dirais je crois qu'on a compris
mais c'est le promoteur qui est inquiet
blot moi j'avais ils sont là ça sert
vraiment à quelque chose de ce qu'il ya
un texte allait le texte aymeric le
texte non bien mec moi que je verrais
bien leur affaire conclue c'est emmanuel
macron dans les manuels macro s'est joué
vraiment arriver dit allez je vois ça
sous le code du travail j'en ai plus
rien à [ __ ] le code du travail la sf
les retraites
les apl c'est par un mandat qu'il a fait
ça un vide greniers studio et nam et
allait d'ailleurs je passais devant
l'elysée mois ya deux jours et il y
avait louis la brocante qui était que sa
petite camionnette comme ça qu'ils
ramassent et tous les acquis sociaux
alors moi j'ai joué et il arrive il
s'agit alors monsieur là nous ça va
comme ça il me dit ballon ça va pas je
suis mort ça va être ça va être court
jeudi matin l'histoire est je chante
jamais ses ventes parce que je vous ai
vu à la télé pas longtemps il dit mais
c'est des rediffusions assez aux rives
réussi des gens se font chier je sais
des rediffusions
mais c'est vrai que ça fait un peu
vieillot comme séries tv alors je dis
mais plus belle la vie ces derniers
fusion non alors ok s'allume cela nous
après je vois j'aurais jamais dû faire
ça alors
je veux voir ma femme 000 jeudi vers otc
pas que j'ai vu a dit manon qui ça j'ai
vu monsieur là nous et je dis ça mais
cela nous le dimanche ça va pas je suis
mort et
je vous ai fait encore preuve de propre
torréon j'adore raconter cette histoire
alors voilà juste je critique emmanuel
macron ça qu'il a fait des trucs super
bien emmanuel macron
ouais c'est un fait ça il a fait quoi
quand il a parlé là au vendeur de
tableaux horticulteurs et asie non vous
autant de temps pour vous safina triste
je sais pas on s'en fout il
il a dit ouais moi je traverse la rue du
boulot du boulot j'en trouve c'est vrai
que les chauffeurs ils n'ont pas le
droit non plus avoir de suite à un
boulot qu'on aime c'est faut passer par
les jobs un peu moisie
ouais ouais moi à la base bon bah je
voulais faire un burger quiz et
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes contrôler la toile quand même
oui je suis content d'être ouais ouais
comment savoir venait avons reçu je vais
me faire virer en garde un truc dans
l'émission l'émission qui m'a un peu
interpellé
c'est en fait qu on voit l'argent
physique je passais les murs on voit des
billets des vrais billets et ça je
trouve qu'en france hurle un peu de mal
avec l'argent les salaires et où on
n'aime pas trop parler salaire on est là
genre tu gagnes combien toi
bernard mais je préfère qu'ils ont pu
[Rires]
intéresser mettre autre chose un break
parce que tu gueules comme un truc
auquel je comprends je te rejoins on se
rejoint dans les limbes
[Applaudissements]